I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, everybody. Good morning, good afternoon, good evening.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，也是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。早上好，下午好，晚上好。
You did it. Paul. Did I get everybody? You did. This week we're talking about New Boss. I was delighted by this episode. Me too. I read the script.
你做到了。保罗。我把所有人都叫齐了吗？齐了。这周我们要聊的是“新老板”。我对这一集感到非常高兴。我也是。我读了剧本。
I read the script and I was cackling. Josh was like, what are you reading? I'm like, it's the shooting drop for New Boss. It was so good. This was season five, episode 20. It was written by Lee Eisenberg and Jean Stupnitsky and directed by Paul Feig. Hit me with a summary. I will.
我读了剧本，笑得前俯后仰。乔什问我在看什么，我说这是《新老板》的拍摄定稿。太棒了。这是第五季第二十集。由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基编剧，保罗·费格执导。给我来个剧情总结。没问题。
There is a New Boss at corporate. They filled the position that used to be held by Jan and then Ryan with new regional supervisor Charles Miner. And he's come into Scranton for a visit. He's going to hobnob with us all day. He is also going to announce some new policies involving our budget, in particular our party budget. Well, to be fair to the new boss, Michael was supposed to let us know.
总公司来了一个新老板。他们填补了之前由简和瑞安担任的职位，新区域主管是查尔斯·迈纳。他来斯克兰顿视察了。他要在我们这儿转悠一整天。他还宣布了一些关于我们预算的新政策，特别是我们的派对预算。嗯，对新老板公平起见，迈克尔本该提前通知我们的。
He was. But once again, he did not. And instead, he started planning his own 15th anniversary party. He's been working at Dunder Mifflin for 15 years and he wants to have a big party. Big, big party. Things do not go well with Michael and Charles or with Jim and Charles. Oh, that was so fun. It's maybe one of my favorite runners ever.
他是该通知的。但又一次，他没有这么做。相反，他开始筹划自己的15周年庆典。他在邓德米夫林工作了15年，他想办个大派对。超级大派对。迈克尔和查尔斯，还有吉姆和查尔斯之间的事情进展得可不太顺利。哦，那太有趣了。这可能是我最喜欢的支线剧情之一了。
Watching Jim be sort of like on the outs with someone and feeling like embarrassed was so good. So, so fun. Michael is spinning out. He tries to get David Wallace on the phone. He can't. So he drives to New York where things are going to take a dramatic turn. Bum, bum, bum.
看吉姆和某人闹僵并感到尴尬的样子真是太棒了。太有趣了。迈克尔快要急疯了。他试图给大卫·华莱士打电话，但打不通。于是他开车去了纽约，事情将在那里发生戏剧性的转折。咚，咚，咚。
Fast fact number one, I mentioned there's a new boss in town. Oh, please give me the character breakdown. That person is Idris Elba. Yep. All right. Yes, it is. Let's get this out of the way. Let's just roll up our sleeves and talk about Idris for a second.
趣事一，我提到镇上来了个新老板。哦，请给我介绍一下这个角色。这个人就是伊德里斯·埃尔巴。没错。好的。是的，就是他。让我们开门见山吧。让我们卷起袖子，花点时间聊聊伊德里斯。
Idris is the most beautiful man I have ever laid my eyes on. He is. And I want to say I've laid my eyes on some gentlemen, famous gentlemen. He's not just beautiful. There is just, I don't know how to explain it, you guys, when you know those people that walk in a room and you just go, damn, it's a whole aura. Yeah, it's a presence. We got a fan question from Anna B and Ally C. How did Idris Elba end up on the show?
伊德里斯是我见过最美丽的男人。他真的是。而且我想说我见过不少绅士，著名的绅士。他不仅仅是长得好看。我不知道该怎么向你们解释，当你知道那些走进房间的人，会让你不禁感叹“哇”的时候，他自带一种气场。对，是一种存在感。我们收到了来自安娜·B和艾莉·C的粉丝提问：伊德里斯·埃尔巴是怎么加入这部剧的？
Randy told me that the role of Charles Miner was written for Idris. He is the only person they ever approached for the role. He said that Idris's name was in the story outline for this episode, which comes out like two months before you even shoot it. And he even sent it to me. It says, interior reception, Charles Miner comma Idris enters. Like, they were like, we want Idris Elba for this role. Oh my gosh, they were planning this pretty far out.
兰迪告诉我，查尔斯·迈纳这个角色是专门为伊德里斯写的。他是他们接触过的唯一一个候选人。他说，伊德里斯的名字出现在这一集的剧本大纲里，这大概在拍摄前两个月就出来了。他甚至把大纲发给我了。上面写着：内景前台，查尔斯·迈纳，逗号，伊德里斯上场。就像是，他们点名就要伊德里斯·埃尔巴演这个角色。天哪，他们筹划得这么早。
Yeah. Well, the writing staff was a really huge fan of the TV show, The Wire. That's what I was going to say. We had a lot of The Wire fans. If you remember that show, everybody was so obsessed with it. It's such a great show. Yeah. And to get Stringer Bell, come on.
对。编剧团队非常喜欢电视剧《火线》。这就是我想说的。我们有很多《火线》迷。如果你还记得那部剧，每个人都为之着迷。那真是一部伟大的剧。对。能请到斯特灵·贝尔，拜托。
I know. Well, he's the second cast member we've had from The Wire, because Amy Ryan was also on The Wire. Yep. We got another fan question from Derek H, who said, I've always wondered how it works with actors who have one accent in real life but have to speak in a different accent for the role. Did Idris Elba speak in his normal British accent between takes, or did he stay in character
我知道。他是我们剧组里第二位来自《火线》的演员，因为艾米·瑞安也演过《火线》。没错。我们收到了来自德里克·H的另一个粉丝提问，他说：我一直很好奇，那些在现实生活中带着某种口音，但为了角色却必须说另一种口音的演员是怎么工作的？伊德里斯·埃尔巴在拍摄间隙是用他正常的英国口音说话，还是
with his American accent the whole time? Yeah, I guess we should mention Idris has a British accent. Which pretty much wrecked us all. Yeah. I mean, if you look like Idris and then you sound like Idris, come on, what were we supposed to do? We were also charmed by him. So charmed, and yes, he did speak in his British accent between takes.
全程都保持着他的美国口音角色设定？对，我想我们应该提一下，伊德里斯有英国口音。这几乎把我们迷得神魂颠倒。对。我是说，如果你长得像伊德里斯，听起来又像伊德里斯，拜托，我们能怎么办？我们也被他迷住了。迷得不行，是的，他在拍摄间隙确实说的是英国口音。
Right. Fast fact number two, more Idris Elba. Okay. I'm sorry. He's too great. We're going to keep talking about him. As you know, since being on The Wire and the office, he has gone on to do a gazillion things, movies, TV shows.
好。趣事二，更多关于伊德里斯·埃尔巴的内容。好吧。我很抱歉。他太棒了。我们要继续聊他。如你们所知，自从演了《火线》和《办公室》之后，他接演了无数的作品，电影、电视节目。
He was most recently in the Suicide Squad. But did you know this? Because I didn't know this. Before he was an actor, he was a DJ. Okay, I did know that. I did know that probably because I was so excited he was coming and I looked up everything about him. Just in case a topic came up, I would know something.
他最近参演了《自杀小队》。但你知道这个吗？因为我以前不知道。在他成为演员之前，他是名DJ。好吧，我知道这个。我之所以知道，可能是因为太兴奋他要来，所以我查阅了关于他的一切。以防万一某个话题出现时，我知道点什么。
Wait, before he was on the show, you Googled him and you're like, I need topics of conversation. I just want to know everything about him. Okay, I did not Google him until we had to prep for this podcast, during which I found out that he is a big time DJ. Growing up, he DJed parties. When he was a struggling actor and he first came to the US, it was really hard for him to get work because he had a special visa. But he was able to get gigs as a DJ.
等等，在他加入剧组之前，你谷歌了他，然后心想：我需要准备聊天话题。我只是想了解他的全部。好吧，直到我们为这个播客做准备时我才谷歌他，期间我发现他是个大牌DJ。在成长过程中，他就在派对上当DJ。当他是个苦苦挣扎的演员刚来到美国时，因为拿的是特殊签证，找工作非常困难。但他设法找到了一些DJ的工作。
He also worked as a bouncer, which I found very interesting. He goes by the name of DJ Big Driss. Now he's done tons of shows. He did a party for Michael Jordan. He DJed the wedding of Prince Harry and Meghan Markle. That I did not know. How did I miss that? You need to do more Googling.
他还当过保镖，我觉得这非常有趣。他使用的艺名是DJ大德里斯。现在他做过无数场演出。他为迈克尔·乔丹办过派对。他是哈里王子和梅根·马克尔婚礼的DJ。这个我真不知道。我怎么会错过这个？你需要多谷歌一下。
Well, I guess I need to re-Google. Yeah. He also played Coachello in 2019. He got rave reviews and he just released a new house track through his label Seven Wallis called Fudge with vocalist Eliza Legzina and I thought we should listen to it. Oh, I'd love that. This man can do no wrong. He, I mean, stop it.
好吧，看来我得重新谷歌了。对。他还在2019年登上了科切拉音乐节。他获得了极佳的评价，并且刚刚通过他的厂牌塞伦·瓦利斯发行了一首名为《Fudge》的新浩室舞曲，合作歌手是伊莉扎·莱格齐娜，我觉得我们应该听听看。哦，我很乐意。这个男人简直无可挑剔。他，我是说，别这样。
Can we get invited to a party where he DJs? It'll never happen. Can we? I don't think it'll happen. I don't think we'll make the list, but I would love it. You know what? We could. Let's go hide in some bushes.
我们能被邀请去他担任DJ的派对吗？这永远不可能发生。能吗？我觉得不会发生。我觉得我们上不了名单，但我很想去。你知道吗？我们可以。我们去灌木丛里躲着。
We'll sneak in. Bush hiders. Bush hiders too. Bush hiders goes to the club. Lady, this is like kind of one of my new life goals, which is to go to a party that address DJs. I want to do it and dance it up. Why don't we wear?
我们偷偷溜进去。灌木丛躲藏者。灌木丛躲藏者也去俱乐部。女士们，这简直是我的人生新目标之一，那就是去一个伊德里斯当DJ的派对。我想去那里尽情热舞。我们穿什么去？
What do you wear to something like that? Can I wear one of my fake flowers? I'm going to say no. Not on this. I agree. I agree. So that address was in that my husband loved was Luther. Yes.
去那种地方穿什么？我能戴我的一朵假花吗？我只能说不。千万别戴这个。我同意。我同意。所以伊德里斯演的那部我丈夫很喜欢的剧是《路德》。对。
Luther is so good. It's so good. He also did a show that he created himself where he plays a DJ called Turn Up Charlie. He's done it all. He's done it all. All right. I will move us on. Fast fact number three is not about Idris, even though it could be.
《路德》太棒了。太棒了。他还制作并主演了一部剧，在里面饰演一个名叫“痛快查理”的DJ。他什么都做过。他什么都会。好了。我把话题推进下去。趣事三不是关于伊德里斯的，尽管它可以是。
Fast fact number three is why is it raining in this episode? All throughout the episode. The whole episode. Pouring rain. Not just raining. Not so much so you can hear it in the talking heads. Yeah. Yeah.
趣事三是，这一集里为什么在下雨？贯穿整集。整集都在下。倾盆大雨。不仅是下雨。雨大得在访谈里都能听到声音。对。对。
I started by looking in the script. I thought, was there a deleted something that tells us why it's raining? I only found one random side comment by Michael. Same. It's in the scene where he's making small talk with Charles and he says, so great weather we're having, huh? Kind of rainy, you know, but still humid, but that was it. That is it.
我首先查阅了剧本。我在想，是不是删掉了什么能告诉我们为什么在下雨的剧情？我只找到了迈克尔随口说的一句话。我也是。就是在那个他和查尔斯闲聊的场景里，他说，今天天气真不错，对吧？有点下雨，你知道的，不过还是挺闷热的，但也就这样了。没了，就这些。
I asked Randy about it and here's what he said. He said, if I recall correctly, we entered this week expecting rain all across LA. In fact, the top of our call sheets for the first two days of shooting say be prepared for rain because they would do that and then they would have extra umbrellas and like all kinds of things for us if we were shooting outside. Randy said the very first day of shooting we had to shoot these driving scenes with Steve. They were supposed to be Michael driving to and from his meeting with David Wallace. Oh, I have some.
我问了兰迪这件事，他是这么说的。他说，如果我没记错的话，我们进组这周预料到整个洛杉矶都会下雨。事实上，我们前两天拍摄通告单的最上方写着：做好下雨的准备，因为他们会这么做，如果我们要在室外拍摄的话，他们会准备好备用雨伞以及各种各样的东西。兰迪说，拍摄的第一天，我们必须和史蒂夫一起拍这些开车镜头的戏。这些本来应该是迈克尔开车去见大卫·华莱士以及回程的戏。哦，我有一些素材。
I'm going to play later for when he leaves. It's amazing. Because they got deleted, right? That's right. Well, I guess while they were shooting this, it was raining all over the car. The wipers are going and all that. That afternoon they moved back to our parking lot where they had to shoot the scenes of Angela and Kelly trying to find Charles.
我等会儿会播放他离开时的画面。太棒了。因为那些被删掉了，对吧？没错。好吧，我猜当他们拍这个的时候，车窗上到处都是雨水。雨刮器一直在动，诸如此类。那天下午他们回到了我们的停车场，他们得在那里拍摄安吉拉和凯莉试图找到查尔斯的戏。
That's when Angela, where you're like gripping his scarf. Yeah. Yeah. In the rain. Yes. He said it was steadily raining the whole afternoon. It was perfect. It became a whole bit, which I know we can get to later, but it made the scene that much
就在那时，安吉拉，就是你紧紧抓住他围巾的那场戏。对。对。在雨中。是的。他说整个下午雨一直在下。太完美了。这成了一个完整的桥段，我知道我们待会儿会聊到，但它让这场戏变得更加
more fun. It's funny because when I first saw it, I asked Randy, did you guys spray down the parking lot with water? And he said, no, that was our rainy day. Yes. It was actually raining. And it was one of the only times I filmed on the office where they didn't care about my hair and makeup.
有趣了。真搞笑，当我第一次看到它的时候，我问兰迪，你们是不是用水管给停车场喷水了？他说，没有，那是我们的雨天。是的。当时真的在下雨。这也是我在《办公室》里拍摄的为数不多的几次他们不介意我的发型和妆容的经历之一。
They were just like, let her get wet. Well, I guess after we finished shooting that one day, it was necessary to match that to the rest of the episode. So Michael Gallenberg and our construction coordinator, Tim James, and the special effects crew led by Ron Nairie added plexiglass sheets over all of the office windows. And they made it rain out every window for the rest of the episode. Well, I think that's so great because I think it would have been weird to have some scenes where it was raining and some not.
他们只是说，让她淋湿吧。好吧，我想在我们拍完那一天的戏之后，为了让其余的剧集连贯起来，这是必须的。于是迈克尔·盖伦伯格和我们的置景统筹蒂姆·詹姆斯，以及由罗恩·奈里领导的特效团队在所有办公室窗户上加了有机玻璃板。他们在整集的剩余时间里让每一扇窗户外面都在下雨。好吧，我觉得这太棒了，因为我觉得如果有些场景下雨而有些场景不下雨会很奇怪。
I like the consistency. I also kind of loved it that we never talked about it. Yeah. Well, remember what you said about how you could hear it? I guess that was kind of an issue because our sound mixer, Ben Patrick, could really hear it through the microphones, especially in the back of the talking heads. So they tried putting down these big fuzzy mats called horse hairs inside of the metal troughs that the water would drip into and then it would get sucked back up and that
我喜欢这种一致性。我也挺喜欢我们从没谈论过这件事的。对。好吧，还记得你说的关于你能听到雨声的事吗？我猜这确实是个问题，因为我们的混音师本·帕特里克真的能通过麦克风听到雨声，特别是在访谈场景的背景音里。所以他们试着在金属排水槽里铺上这种叫做马毛的大型毛茸茸垫子，雨水会滴落到里面，然后被抽回上面，
would just sort of cycle through the window pane to try to quiet the water, but it didn't work 100%. So you can hear the rain in the back of some of these scenes. Randy also wanted me to tell people that the fuzzy mats are not actually made out of horse hair. That was my next question. I said, oh no. Oh no.
这样就会在窗玻璃周围循环，试图让水声变小，但并没有百分之百起效。所以你仍然能在其中一些场景的背景中听到雨声。兰迪还想让我告诉大家，那些毛茸茸的垫子其实并不是用马毛做的。那是我的下一个问题。我说，哦不。哦不。
Hold that. Oh. Randy said that it's, quote, just another old timey holdover from early Hollywood. Well, thank goodness because I was worried for a second. It's fakey, fakey hair, fakey hair. Well, that's all I got, lady. Well, I loved all of that. We should probably take a break and then get into this episode.
等等。哦。兰迪说，用他的话说，这“只是早期好莱坞的一个老式遗留物”。好吧，谢天谢地，因为我刚才还担心了一会儿。那是假毛，假毛，假的毛发。好吧，女士，我收集的就这些了。好吧，我喜欢所有这些。我们或许该休息一下，然后进入正片。
I think so. I've invented a new phrase for today. Oh, yeah? Uh-huh. You want to hear it? Yeah. It's called the fan mail flurry. Oh.
我也这么觉得。我今天发明了一个新词。哦，是吗？嗯哼。想听听吗？好啊。叫做“粉丝来信狂潮”。哦。
And that's when we get tons of mail about a certain one subject in an episode. And this week, there were two fan mail flurries. Jenna coined a phrase, well, I want you to know, I had my husband make a sting in this episode. What? And I will surprise you with it. Let's take a break and we'll be back with new boss. We're going to kick off this episode with a little meeting in the conference room about
意思就是我们会收到大量关于某一集中某个特定主题的来信。这周有两场粉丝来信狂潮。珍娜创造了一个词，好吧，我想让你知道，我让我丈夫为这一集制作了一个音效。什么？我会给你一个惊喜的。我们休息一下，回来后继续聊《新老板》。我们要从会议室里关于
Michael's 15th anniversary celebration. And who is in the party planning committee now? Jim, Dwight, and Pam. Oh, I'm just there to take notes. I don't think I'm really in it. Although later, I guess I am throwing out ideas. You are. Hmm.
迈克尔15周年庆典的一个小会议开始这一集。现在派对策划委员会里都有谁？吉姆，德怀特和帕姆。哦，我在那儿只是为了做笔记。我觉得我并不真正属于这个委员会。虽然过一会儿，我好像确实在提意见。你确实提了。嗯。
How'd I make my way back in? I think Jim wrangled you in. And I'm going to say, traitor. Dwight is going to pitch the idea of a 15-minute round of applause followed by a 15-minute moment of silence. What would that 30 minutes be like if you're an audience member? It's 30 minutes total. It's so hilarious to me.
我是怎么重回委员会的？我想是吉姆把你拉进来的。我要说，叛徒。德怀特将提出一个为期15分钟的雷鸣般掌声，接着是15分钟的默哀。如果你作为观众，那30分钟会是怎样的体验？总共30分钟。这对我来说太搞笑了。
Like, I know we could never have done this, but I would have loved to film that. And I would have loved for all of us to have had to clap for 15 minutes. That would be so difficult. I know. And then try watching it. Well, the camera pans over and Jim is wearing a tuxedo. And wow, this is really going to haunt him later. He's wearing a tuxedo.
就像，我知道我们永远不可能真的这么做，但我很想拍那场戏。而且我真希望我们所有人都得鼓掌15分钟。那太难了。我知道。然后试着看下去。镜头摇过去，吉姆穿着一件燕尾服。哇，这以后真的会成为他的阴魂不散的噩梦。他穿着燕尾服。
He's slicked his hair. He went all out to rub it in Dwight's face about his dress code memo. Dwight is going to continue to list off activities that Jim is sort of shooting down. Jim is clearly influencing Michael, right? So Dwight says a string quartet performing classy Cal music and ice sculpture surrounded by chocolate-covered strawberries. An ice sculpture of Michael. Yeah.
他把头发梳得油光发亮。他全力以赴，就是为了用着装规范备忘录来气德怀特。德怀特继续列举了一系列被吉姆一一否决的活动。吉姆明显在影响迈克尔，对吧？所以德怀特说：由弦乐四重奏演奏高雅的卡尔音乐，以及四周摆满巧克力草莓的冰雕。一个迈克尔造型的冰雕。对。
This scene would have continued. Part of it was edited out. In the script, Jim says, you can't buy classy. You can't teach classy. You're born with it. Michael has it. Pam has it. Dwight goes, really?
这场戏本会继续的。其中一部分被剪掉了。在剧本中，吉姆说，你买不来高雅。你教不出高雅。那是天生的。迈克尔有。帕姆有。德怀特说，真的吗？
Pam has it? And then Michael says, Pam has class coming out of her ass. Wow. Pam says, thank you, Michael. That was very classy of you to say. And then Dwight's like, well, I'm sorry, I don't know what classy is. That is amazing. I love that.
帕姆有？然后迈克尔说，帕姆的屁股里都能散发出高雅。哇。帕姆说，谢谢你，迈克尔。你说得真高雅。然后德怀特说，好吧，对不起，我不知道什么叫高雅。这太棒了。我太喜欢了。
You know, in this meeting, one of the things they're going to decide is classy is Mr. Peanut. Yes. Mr. Peanut is the logo for the Planters Peanut Company, which, listen to this, was founded in 1906 in Wilkesbury, Pennsylvania. Oh, that's awesome. How about that? And I have more to say about Mr. Peanut. What?
你知道，在这场会议中，他们认定具有高雅气质的东西之一就是小花生先生。是的。小花生先生是惑星花生公司的标志，你们听这个，它于1906年创立于宾夕法尼亚州的威尔克斯伯里。哦，太棒了。怎么样？我还有更多关于小花生先生的话要说。什么？
This peanut is like one of the best-known, most iconic images in advertising history. Oh, yeah. I have it in my mind instantly. Yeah. Mr. Peanut, I picture him with this hat and they have a cane and a little monocle. Yeah. You know it. Yeah.
这个花生简直是广告史上最广为人知、最具标志性的形象之一。哦，对。我脑海中立刻浮现出他的样子。对。小花生先生，我脑海里画着他戴着这顶帽子，拿着一根手杖，还戴着一幅小单片眼镜。对。你懂的。对。
You know Mr. Peanut. He kind of kicks one leg over the other when he stands. He does. Yeah. So, here's where he came from. They did a contest to have someone design a logo for the company and a young schoolboy by the name of Antonio Gentile submitted a drawing of an anthropomorphic peanut. And he won the contest and he got $5.
你认识小花生先生。他站着的时候，一条腿会搭在另一条腿上。确实如此。对。所以，他的来历是这样的。他们举办了一场比赛，让人们为公司设计一个标志，一个名叫安东尼奥·琴蒂莱的年轻小学生提交了一幅拟人化花生的画作。他赢得了比赛并得到了5美元。
$5. $5. But I'll have you know that the founder of the company, his name was Amidio Obici, if I'm saying that correctly, he was so taken with this little boy that he ended up paying his way through college and all of his siblings way through college. Oh, I like hearing that. So I guess he got $5 and a college education for himself and his siblings. There was a commercial artist named Andrew Wallach who added the monocle, the top hat
5美元。5美元。但我得告诉你们，公司的创始人，他的名字叫阿米迪奥·奥比奇（如果我没发错音的话），他对这个小男孩非常喜爱，以至于他最终资助了这个小男孩以及他的所有兄弟姐妹的大学学费。哦，我很高兴听到这个。所以我想他为自己和兄弟姐妹赢得了5美元和高等教育。有个叫安德鲁·瓦拉赫的商业美术师添加了单片眼镜、高顶礼帽
and the cane. So it was a bit of a two-hander, however, the plot thickens. What? There is a disputed claim that a different artist actually added the monocle top hat and cane. The family of Frank P. Creasy claims that he did it. He was a Wilkes-Berry artist and also the head of the Suffolk planter plant. They think he did it.
和手杖。所以这是两人的合作，然而，情节变得扑朔迷离。什么？有一种有争议的说法称，其实是另一个艺术家添加了单片眼镜、高顶礼帽和手杖。弗兰克·P·克雷西的家人声称是他做的。他是威尔克斯伯里的艺术家，也是萨福克惑星植物工厂的负责人。他们认为是干的。
So mom detective, what happened? Thank you, Angela. There are no sources still in circulation that can positively identify the artist. We know the little boy started it all. But who added the monocle top hat and cane? We'll never know. We'll never really know. There you go.
所以妈妈侦探，到底怎么回事？谢谢你，安吉拉。目前市面上没有任何资料能够确切地辨认出这位艺术家。我们知道是由那个小男孩开启这一切的。但究竟是谁添加了单片眼镜、高顶礼帽和手杖？我们永远不会知道了。我们永远都不会真正知道了。就是这样。
On this episode of Mom Detective. Is that going to be unsatisfying if the episodes of Mom Detective's end with, we'll never know? I think many of them will in that way. Well I have a little thing to share about the script because, you know, I loved the shooting draft of the script and Jenna and I have talked to you guys about how we would have a scene and then sometimes in the moment we'd play around with it and it would change right there in the moment.
在本期《妈妈侦探》节目中。如果《妈妈侦探》的每一集都以“我们永远都不会知道了”结尾，会不会让人觉得很不满足？我想其中很多集都会以那种方式结尾。好吧，我有一点关于剧本的事情想分享，因为，你知道，我喜欢剧本的拍摄定稿，而且珍娜和我跟你们聊过，我们有时会演完一场戏，然后在当场即兴发挥，情况就会在现场发生改变。
So I think this is a great example and I don't think our show could have been like this without Steve Carell. I'll tell you why. In the shooting draft, Michael is the one that has the whole speech about Mr. Peanut. Not Jim. Michael says this needs to be classy like the grand opening of a car dealership or Mr. Peanut. And then Dwight says Mr. Peanut's not classy.
所以我认为这是一个很好的例子，而且我觉得如果没有史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，我们的剧就不可能会是这样。我来告诉你为什么。在拍摄定稿中，是迈克尔发表了关于小花生先生的整段演讲。而不是吉姆。迈克尔说这需要像汽车经销店盛大开业或小花生先生那样高雅。然后德怀特说小花生先生并不高雅。
He's just a regular peanut dressed in a top hat and cane and Michael says that's what makes him classy. But when you watch the episode, it's a two-hander. Michael says we need it to be classy like a car dealership. Jim says our Mr. Peanut and it's a two-hander and it makes the scene so much better because then Michael and Jim are kind of in cahoots about this, right? And Dwight's the odd man out. I bet that happened on the day.
他只是个戴着高顶礼帽和手杖的普通花生，迈克尔说这正是他高雅的地方。但当你观看这一集时，这是两个人的对手戏。迈克尔说我们需要它像汽车经销店那样高雅。吉姆说或者小花生先生，这是一场对手戏，这让这场戏好太多了，因为这样迈克尔和吉姆就在这事儿上算是一伙的了，对吧？而德怀特成了局外人。我敢打赌那是现场发挥的。
Yeah. That's so great. Isn't that cool? I know these are sort of tiny moments, but I just think it speaks to our creative collaboration on the show. Absolutely. Angela, this cold open also created fan mail flurry number one. Okay.
对。太棒了。不是很酷吗？我知道这些算是微小的时刻，但我只是觉得这说明了我们在剧中的创意合作。绝对的。安吉拉，这个片头冷笑点还引发了第一场粉丝来信狂潮。好吧。
I feel like I'd need a Sting, you mentioned Sting and now I want a fan mail flurry. Like stuff going into an inbox. People have a lot to say about whether or not this is Michael's 15th year at Dunder Mifflin or not. Let me get you started with Maddie L. Fan mail, fan mail, fan mail flurry. Hey, I love it. Maddie says, per this episode's air date, Michael would have started work at Dunder
我觉得我需要一个音效，你提到了音效，现在我也想要一个粉丝来信狂潮的音效。就像东西塞进收件箱一样。大家对于这究竟是不是迈克尔在邓德米夫林的第15年有很多话要说。让我从玛蒂·L的来信开始。粉丝来信，粉丝来信，粉丝来信狂潮。嘿，我喜欢这个。玛蒂说，按照这一集的播出日期，迈克尔开始在邓德米夫林工作的时间应该是1994年3月19日。
Mifflin on March 19th, 1994. But during Michael's last dundies, the cast sings the song 9,986,000 minutes in tribute to how long he's worked at the company. And if you do the math from that air date, that would mean that Michael actually worked at Dunder Mifflin for 19 years. So much math. If you back it up to this episode, that would be 17 years at this point. Huh.
但在迈克尔的最后一场邓迪奖颁奖典礼上，演员们合唱了歌曲《9,986,000分钟》，以此向他在公司工作的时间致敬。如果你根据那个播出日期做数学计算，那就意味着迈克尔实际上在邓德米夫林工作了19年。好多的数学计算。如果你把时间倒推回这一集，那此时应该是第17年。哈。
Kelly S. got in on this and said, in the negotiation from season three, Daryl says that Michael has been working at Dunder Mifflin for 14 years. This is two years later, so that would make this his 16th year. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. How long has Michael been working at Dunder Mifflin? It's shifting this 16, 17 years. This feels like one of those math word problems on a test, like about the train that goes
凯莉·S也加入了进来，她说：在第三季的谈判中，达里尔说迈克尔在邓德米夫林已经工作了14年。这是两年后，所以这将是他的第16年。嗯-hmm。嗯-hmm。迈克尔到底在邓德米夫林工作了多久？这在第16年和第17年之间摇摆。这感觉就像考试中的那种数学应用题，比如关于去
to Pennsylvania, but then stops off in New York and blah, blah, blah, guys. I've seen teachers do that where they'll do a math word problem using office characters and stuff. I think that's really fun. I do too. You still wouldn't be good at it, though. No, because it's still math. Bingo.
宾夕法尼亚州的火车，中途却在纽约停下之类的，伙计们。我见过老师们出这样的题，他们会用办公室的角色什么的来出数学应用题。我觉得这真的很有趣。我也这么觉得。不过你还是不擅长，对吧。对，因为这依然是数学。宾果。
Were you good in math in school? Because I was very good at math in school, and now, I mean, everyone knows my calculator story where I tried to add without a calculator for a year, and I don't know. It's left me. Like, I can barely help my 10-year-old with his math homework now. Well. What happened to me? I mean, I was really good.
你在学校里数学好吗？因为我上学时数学非常好，而现在，大家都知道我的计算器故事，我曾经有一年尝试不用计算器做加法，然后我不行了。它离我而去了。比如我现在几乎辅导不了我10岁儿子的数学作业。好吧。我这是怎么了？我是说，我以前真的很强。
I was like, you know, 98th percentile in the math tests and stuff. I was a solid B student in math, totally fine, all the way up to Algebra 2, and then I had the option to take language over trig, and I love language. I love speaking other languages, and so I actually went all the way up to Spanish 4, but I was able to opt out of trig to do language. I loved trigonometry. I didn't take it. I didn't care for geometry, but I loved trigonometry, algebra, all of that.
我当时大概处于数学测试的第98百分位之类的高水平。我数学是个稳固的B等生，完全没问题，一直到代数2，然后我有机会选修语言而不是三角函数，我热爱语言。我喜欢说别的语言，所以我实际上一直学到了西班牙语4，但我可以选择放弃三角函数来学语言。我热爱三角函数。我没选它。我不喜欢几何，但我热爱三角函数、代数，所有这些。
But it has left me. Let's get back to the episode, because a gentleman named Charles has arrived, and he would like to speak with Michael. Hold up, but first, I have a very tall plant alert. What's happening? We haven't had a plant at reception alert in a long time, two minutes, 23 seconds. This might be Pam's tallest potted plant. I just want to go on record.
但它已经离我而去了。让我们回到这一集中来，因为一位名叫查尔斯的身士已经到了，他想和迈克尔谈谈。等等，但首先，我有紧急通报：超级高大的植物警报。发生什么事了。我们好久没有前台植物警报了，2分23秒。这可能是帕姆最高的盆栽植物了。我要做个记录。
You know, it's interesting, I was just looking at the watercolor that Morgan did of Pam's plants. Yes. There is a plant on there that's very, very tall. It's down in the corner. It's so tall, it actually encroaches on one of the other plants. Could this be that plant? Maybe it is.
你知道，很有意思，我刚才正看着摩根画的帕姆植物的水彩画。是的。上面有一株非常非常高的植物。它在角落里。它太高了，甚至侵占了另一株植物的空间。会是那株植物吗？也许是的。
The watercolor painting of Pam's plants that we're talking about is done by this fantastic artist. Her name is Morgan. You can find her on Instagram, Morgan Gissell Art. Morgan G-E-S-E-L-L-A-R-T. You guys, she's painted all of Pam's plants. She calls it Beasley's Botanicals. You can get it as a mug, and she was kind enough to gift me with the original watercolor,
我们正在谈论的帕姆植物的水彩画是由这位了不起的艺术家创作的。她叫摩根。你可以在Instagram上找到她，摩根·吉塞尔艺术（Morgan Gissell Art）。摩根，G-E-S-E-L-L-A-R-T。伙计们，她画了帕姆所有的植物。她称之为比斯利的植物学。你可以把它印在马克杯上，她还非常友善地将原创水彩画赠送给我，
which I treasure. I know, and you know what she did? She did all of Angela Martin's outfits in a watercolor painting. I have it hanging in my bedroom. So yes, there is a very tall plant at reception. I didn't notice the plant, Angela, because my eyes were on Idris Elba entering the room. Yes. The plant that the minor has arrived at two minutes and 50 seconds, Angela Martin looks
我将其视为珍宝。我知道，而且你知道她做了什么吗？她把安吉拉·马丁所有的服装都画成了一幅水彩画。我把它挂在我的卧室里。所以，是的，前台有一株非常高的植物。我没注意到那株植物，安吉拉，因为我的眼睛全盯在走进房间的伊德里斯·埃尔巴身上了。是的。这位迈纳先生在2分50秒时抵达，安吉拉·马丁上下打量
him up and down. Michael welcomes him in and says that everybody needs to go into the break room because he has a surprise that he is setting up. Yeah, he whispers to Dwight, I have to get the fish ready. Yep. Gross. What's a what? And now for a segment I'd like to call History in the World.
着他。迈克尔欢迎他进来，并说每个人都需要去休息室，因为他准备了一个惊喜。对，他小声道：我得把鱼准备好。没错。真恶心。什么什么？现在进入我喜欢称之为“世界历史”的环节。
What? History in the break room. I made my husband do that like last night in his car. You can tell. I'm like, do it in the car, in the minivan, it'll sound better. History in the break room. So Michael needs Dwight to distract Charles and the group. They go in the break room.
什么？休息室里的历史。我昨天晚上让我丈夫在他的车里录了这个。听得出来。我说：在车里录，在面包车里录，这样听起来更好。休息室里的历史。所以迈克尔需要德怀特去转移查尔斯和大家的注意力。他们去了休息室。
He bores them with the history of Scranton. We only hear one sentence of this and I also remember Rain had a hard time not laughing and you can kind of see him starting that twinkle when he starts to break. Do you know there was a whole entire speech in the script? I do because I remember that Rain had to memorize a huge monologue about the history of Scranton. In particular, the anthracite coal mining communities. You guys, when we saw the episode and only one line made it, I just know Rain was like,
他用斯克兰顿的历史折磨他们。我们只听到了一句台词，我也记得雷恩当时很难忍住不笑，当他开始笑场时，你差不多能看到他眼中闪烁的光芒。你知道剧本里其实有一整段演讲吗？我知道，因为我记得雷恩必须背诵一大段关于斯克兰顿历史的独白。特别是无烟煤矿业社区。伙计们，当我们看到正片里只有一句台词保留下来时，我敢肯定雷恩当时心里在想：
son of a, this is what he had to learn. Originally founded in 1866, Scranton quickly became one of Pennsylvania's largest anthracite coal mining communities. The nation's thirst for energy during World War II was slacked by the extensive strip mining operations in the area. But in 1959, the Knox mine disaster all but erased the local mining industry. The area was then scarred by abandoned coal mining structures, strip mines, and slag heaps, which give mute testimony to the city's industrial past.
该死的，这就是他不得不背的东西。最初建于1866年，斯克兰顿迅速成为宾夕法尼亚州最大的无烟煤矿业社区之一。二战期间国家对能源的渴望得到了该地区广泛的露天采矿作业的满足。但在1959年，诺克斯矿难几乎抹去了当地的采矿业。该地区随后留下了废弃的煤矿结构、露天矿和矿渣堆，这些都无声地见证了这座城市的工业过去。
So anyway, what's up with you? Can you believe he learned that whole thing and one line made it? The first line and the ending line made it. Oh my gosh. Well, then Michael is going to come in and he says, all right, everybody come to the conference room. And you know, he does that big gesture where his hand hits the door frame. Yeah, he does this windmills like motion.
所以总之，你最近怎么样？你能相信他背了整段内容，结果只保留了一句台词吗？第一句台词和最后一句台词保留了下来。哦天哪。好吧，接着迈克尔要走进来了，他说：好了，大家都去会议室吧。你知道，他做那个大动作时，手拍到了门框上。对，他做了个风车般的动作。
And then he does the thing that Steve does so well where he's like, oh, right, where he like grunts. It was the same thing that cracked me up when he would get out of Pam's chair after it had sunk down. Our when Kevin sat on him as Santa, it's the same noise. It's like, yeah, he does these suppressed groans so well. Well, that whole thing was scripted. I looked it up and this is what the script said about that.
然后他做了那个史蒂夫做得极好的动作，就是那种：哦，对了，发出咕哝声。每当他从陷下去的帕姆椅子里站起来时，都会让我笑得前仰后合，就是那个动作。或者是凯文当圣诞老人坐在他身上时，也是这个声音。就像，是的，他太擅长发出这种被压抑的呻吟声了。好吧，整段都是有剧本的。我查了一下，剧本上是这么写的。
It says, Michael windmill motions for people to follow, but nails his hand on top of the entrance he winces. So that little moment was scripted for Steve and he was amazing. He was amazing because you're not sure. You're not sure if that was just him mucking around or if it really happened. Well, once in the conference room, Michael is going to present an array of bagels that have been cut into the shape of a C for Charles. Took them all night.
上面写着：迈克尔做着风车手势让大家跟上，但他的手重重地撞在入口顶部，他疼得咧嘴。所以那个小小的时刻是为史蒂夫写进剧本的，他演得太棒了。他太棒了，因为你拿不准。你拿不准那究竟是他瞎胡闹还是真的发生了。好吧，一到会议室，迈克尔就展示了一盘切成查尔斯名字首字母“C”形的面包圈。整晚都在做。
Yeah. I have to say, when I saw this, I thought this was a very Ted Lasso move. What? Couldn't you see Ted Lasso and beard doing something like this? Like making all the bagels into like a certain letter. Am I crazy? No, it's a Ted Lasso. I can see it.
对。我必须说，当我看到这一幕时，我觉得这非常有泰德·拉索的风格。什么？难道你看不出泰德·拉索和比尔会做出这种事吗？比如把所有的面包圈做成某个特定的字母。我是疯了吗？不，这就是泰德·拉索。我能想象到。
And this just got my brain sort of thinking about how there are actually a lot of things that Michael does that Ted Lasso also kind of does, but he does it better and more appropriate. You guys were talking about the show Ted Lasso with Jason Sedakis, Bill Lawrence, executive producer show. He's amazing. It just won a gazillion Emmys. Yeah. Yeah.
这让我的大脑开始思考，其实迈克尔做的很多事情，泰德·拉索也有点在做，但他做得更好、更得体。你们之前在讨论由杰森·苏戴奇斯、执行制片人比尔·劳伦斯制作的电视剧《泰德·拉索》。他太棒了。刚赢得了一大堆艾美奖。对。对。
The cast is phenomenal. But I was just watching an episode the other day where Ted Lasso is like riding lawn mower with the guy. Uh-huh. Couldn't you see Michael Scott doing that? Michael and Dwight. Yeah. I don't know.
演员阵容太棒了。但我前几天正好看了一集，里面泰德·拉索和那家伙一起骑着割草机。嗯哼。难道你看不出迈克尔·斯科特做这种事吗？迈克尔和德怀特。对。我不知道。
I was seeing some parallels and it was kind of charming me. And I think also because I thought it was kind of cute that he made the bagels into a sea. I did too. It's just that his presentation of it was so sad. It was just on a bunch of paper towels. Well, and also like just his buildup. His buildup was so huge. Yeah.
我看到了一些相似之处，这让我觉得挺迷人的。而且我也觉得，他把面包圈做成C形挺可爱的。我也觉得。只是他展示的方式太悲惨了。就摆在一堆纸巾上。好吧，还有，就像他的铺垫一样。他的铺垫太宏大了。对。
Oh. Ted would have had them on a tray and that would have made the difference. Yeah. And he's also Ted and not Michael. Anyway, we both love Ted Lasso if you can't tell. Definitely. We just like it. Michael has a talking head.
哦。泰德会把它们放在托盘上，那就完全不同了。对。而且他是泰德而不是迈克尔。不管怎样，如果你们看不出来的话，我们俩都很喜欢《泰德·拉索》。绝对的。我们就是喜欢。迈克尔有一个单人访谈。
He's super excited about what his relationship is going to be like with Charles. They hung out at corporate. They got along. He said, it's going to be mental. He's so excited. You guys, did you notice that this scene starts off with Creed walking out of the conference room just eating salmon out of his hand? No.
他对未来和查尔斯的关系会是什么样感到超级兴奋。他们在总公司一起待过。他们相处得很好。他说：这太疯狂了。他太激动了。伙计们，你们注意到这一幕是从克里德手里拿著三文鱼走出会议室开始的吗？没有。
He's just throwing salmon in his mouth. You can only see him from the back. It's such a small detail. I was cracking up. You know, for a technical reason, they needed Creed or someone to leave the conference room because then the camera follows that person to Angela and Kelly. And Creed, I know, I know he just was eating that fish that was not in the script. This is when Charles is going to notice Jim's tucks.
他正把三文鱼往嘴里塞。你只能看到他的背影。这是一个如此微小的细节。我当时笑得前俯后仰。你知道的，出于技术原因，他们需要克里德或某人离开会议室，因为随后镜头会跟着那个人去找安吉拉和凯莉。而且克里德，我知道，我知道他当时只是在吃那条根本不在剧本里的鱼。正是在这个时候，查尔斯注意到了吉姆的燕尾服。
Oh, they get off to a bumpy start. They really, really do. Pam has to like gently pull Jim away. That was really hard for me. I would laugh every time I had to do that because it was funny to me. It was so funny and you guys, right after this awkward meeting between Jim and Charles and Pam pulling him away, there was a Charles minor talking head. What was it?
哦，他们的开局很不顺利。真的非常不顺利。帕姆不得不轻轻把吉姆拉开。这对我和我来说真的很难。每次我得这么做时我都会笑，因为我觉得这太好笑了。太搞笑了，伙计们，就在吉姆和查尔斯这次尴尬的会面以及帕姆把他拉开之后，有一个查尔斯·迈纳的单人访谈。内容是什么？
Okay. Oh, I wish it would have made it. This is what they would have cut to. In business school, they taught us how to assess operations and identify waste. It's rare the waste so readily identifies itself. So it's very clear if that had stayed in how Charles sees Jim. Well, Pam and Jim have a talking head together and in this talking head, Pam says he just had to wear his tucks today, took him 40 minutes to get ready.
好的。哦，我真希望这段能播出来。这是他们本打算剪掉的内容。在商学院里，他们教我们如何评估运营和识别浪费。很少有浪费会如此轻易地自我暴露。所以如果这段保留下来，查尔斯如何看待吉姆就会一目了然。好吧，帕姆和吉姆有一个联合访谈，在这个访谈里，帕姆说他今天非得穿他的燕尾服，花了他40分钟才准备好。
She's so amused. We got a fan question from Lola C and AK Sangra. Why didn't Jim just take off his blazer and tie? Because then it would have just been like kind of a white button down shirt and pants. I don't think it would have mattered. That's a weird white shirt, right? It does have the tuxedo collar, yeah, but it would have helped. It would have maybe helped a little.
她觉得太好玩了。我们收到了来自罗拉·C和AK·桑格拉的粉丝提问：为什么吉姆不直接脱掉西装外套和领带呢？因为那样的话，看起来就有点像一件普通的白衬衫和裤子了。我觉得那也没什么关系。那是一件很奇怪的白衬衫，对吧？它确实有燕尾服领子，对，但那样会有所帮助。也许会有那么一点点帮助。
I'm going to say good point, guys. This whole dynamic of Jim and Charles getting off on the wrong foot, this is going to extend because Idris is going to be on for five more episodes and this is going to extend through this whole storyline with him. And this was a dynamic Gene and Lee told me that the writers really wanted to examine. They loved this idea that someone was going to put Jim back on his heels, that there was a character that was immune to Jim's charm and wit, and they thought it would be very, very funny to see Jim be so disarmed.
我要说，大家问得好。吉姆和查尔斯出师不利的整个动态关系将延续下去，因为伊德里斯还要演另外五集，这种动态将贯穿他和他的整个剧情线。这是吉恩和兰迪告诉我编剧们真的很想探讨的一种动态。他们喜欢这样一个创意：有人会把吉姆逼得措手不及，有一个角色对吉姆的魅力和机智免疫，他们觉得看到吉姆如此毫无招架之力会非常非常有趣。
It was. I couldn't get enough of it. I loved it. I loved John, everything about John, having to play this piece of his character. When you know John had so much fun, that was just always really cool when you got to examine another side of your character. I loved that too. I always loved when there would be little shifts like when Pam and Dwight were friends,
确实如此。我看不够。我太喜欢了。我喜欢约翰，喜欢约翰为了诠释角色的这一面所做的一切。当你看到约翰玩得那么开心时，每当你能探索你角色的另一面时，总是非常酷的。我也很喜欢。我总是很喜欢那些小小的转变，比如帕姆和德怀特成为朋友的时候，
you know? I love suspicious bitch, you know? But now one of my favorite elements of our show is when Michael has to introduce a new person to anyone in the office. He gets so personal. He has done this time and time again. He brings over the accounting department and then tells all of our dating history. He tells about Oscar's breakup with Gil and how Angela has had sexual relations with Andy,
你知道吗？我喜欢充满怀疑的碧池，你知道的？但现在我剧中最喜欢的元素之一，就是迈克尔不得不向办公室里的任何人介绍新人的时候。他总是表现得极其私人。他一次又一次地这么做。他把会计部门叫过来，然后讲我们所有的约会史。他讲奥斯卡和吉尔的分手，讲安吉拉和安迪有过性关系，
and then Idris just interrupts him and is like, you know, Michael, I don't need to know everyone's sexual history. And he's like, good, because we're getting to Kevin and he's got nada. I just love it every time, every time I look forward to it. The writers must have loved having to come up with new ways for Michael to introduce the same people. It really reminds me of how children like sometimes introduce people. Yes.
然后伊德里斯直接打断了他，说道：你知道的，迈克尔，我不需要知道每个人的性生活史。他说：太好了，因为我们要讲到凯文了，而他是一无所有。我就是每次都笑死，每一次我都无比期待。编剧们当时一定很喜欢想出各种新方法让迈克尔去介绍同一拨人。这真的让我想起小孩子有时候是怎么介绍别人的。是的。
Like my mom has this story of me. I was probably like eight years old and we were at the grocery store checkout and it was me and my mom and my friend. And the woman thought my friend was my mom's daughter and she was like, oh, she looks just like you. And I said, that's not her daughter. I'm her daughter. These guys are hair and my mom was like, thank you.
就像我妈讲过关于我的故事。我当时大概八岁左右，我们在杂货店结账，当时是我、我妈妈和我朋友。那个女人以为我朋友是我妈妈的女儿，她说：哦，她长得太像你了。我说：这不是她女儿。我是她女儿。这些人是头发，我妈当时就说：谢谢你。
But that's how Michael introduces people. No, it's true. He's like, how could I introduce this person? You know what? They only have eight toes. What? Here's something interesting. Charles clearly realizes he needs to take over here for a second.
但迈克尔就是这样介绍别人的。不，真的。他就好像：我怎么才能介绍这个人呢？你知道吗？他们只有八个脚趾。什么？这里有个有趣的事。查尔斯显然意识到他需要在这里接管一下局面了。
He's all business. He is. And he wants everybody to know that Dunder Mifflin is cutting 3% across the board. They will no longer be matching 401K contributions. All over time has to go through corporate. And here's the big one. They're putting a freeze on discretionary spending, including parties, petty cash, supplies and parties.
他全神贯注于工作。他是认真的。他想让每个人都知道邓德米夫林正在全面削减3%的开支。他们将不再匹配401K退休福利。所有的加班费都必须通过总公司审批。还有最重要的一点：他们将冻结全盘自主性开支，包括派对、零用现金、办公用品和派对。
Oh boy. Oh boy. And immediately, Michael starts to spiral. He's like, OK, Charles, thanks for coming in. Thank you. Thank you so much. And Charles is like, no, I'm actually going to stay today. And we got some mail about that.
哦天哪。哦天哪。紧接着，迈克尔开始情绪失控了。他心想：好吧，查尔斯，谢谢你能来。谢谢。非常感谢。而查尔斯却说：不，我今天其实要留下来。我们收到了一些关于这件事的来信。
People were like, why is David Wallace having Charles Minor babysit Michael all day when just a couple episodes ago, he was so impressed with Michael that he was sending him out to speak to other branches? I never saw this as Charles babysitting Michael in particular. I just saw this as this guy who's new to the company. He's an executive. He's just going to go around to every branch and spend a day at the branch. He's going to get to know the people.
大家都在问，为什么大卫·华莱士会让查尔斯·迈纳整天像带孩子一样看着迈克尔，明明就在几集前，他对迈克尔赞赏有加，甚至还派他去其他分公司演讲？我从不觉得这是查尔斯在特地带迈克尔。我只是觉得这就像是个刚来公司的新人，他是个高管。他只是打算去每个分公司待上一天，熟悉一下各个分公司。他要去认识大家。
He's clearly going to bring them lunch. You know, this wasn't a babysitting thing where Michael was singled out. This is just what he's doing to kind of get to know people. Exactly. This is standard practice. He's the VP of the Northeast region. He's got to get to know his region. Well, while Charles is setting up in the conference room, Michael is going to get David Wallace
他显然会给他们带午餐。你知道的，这根本不是什么把迈克尔单独拎出来当成带孩子的任务。这只是他为了解大家而做的事情。没错。这都是标准流程。他是东北大区的副总裁。他必须了解他管辖的大区。好吧，就在查尔斯在会议室里布置的时候，迈克尔给大卫·华莱士
on the phone because it was his understanding that he would not be managed. This is one of my favorite lines that Michael says in the whole episode. Yeah. He's telling David. He says to David, he doesn't understand why they can't just leave the position vacant and then here's my favorite line, truth be told, I think I thrive under a lack of accountability. I know. Michael asks David if he will be attending his anniversary party and if hiring Cirque
打了电话，因为在他的理解中，他是不会被别人管理的。这是迈克尔在这整集中我最喜欢的台词之一。对。他在跟大卫说。他对大卫说，他不明白为什么他们不能让这个职位一直空着，然后是我最说喜欢的台词，老实说，我觉得我在缺乏问责制的环境下才能茁壮成长。我懂。迈克尔问大卫他是否会出席他的周年派对，以及雇佣太阳
de Soleil performers as salaried employees would help with the year-end tax stuff. No response. I counted. It's a seven second silence. It's so perfect. And then Dwight, who by the way they revealed was there the whole time, it's classic Michael Dwight scene. Dwight's like, maybe he hung up and then he's like, no.
马戏团的表演者作为全职员工是否有助于年底的税务问题。没有回应。我数过了。足足沉默了七秒钟。简直太绝了。然后德怀特——顺便说一下，他们透露德怀特其实一直在那儿——这是一个经典的迈克尔和德怀特场景。德怀特说，也许他挂了电话，然后他又说，不对。
Who comes out of this phone call? He's decided, all right, he's going to try to get to know Charles. He's going to make an effort. He's going to ask him some personal questions right away. He's like, tell me something you've never told anyone before. Charles is like, no. And before we get any further into this crazy meeting, because there is a scene that was deleted that I want to read to you.
谁会从这个电话里出来呢？他决定了，好吧，他要试着去了解查尔斯。他要做出努力。他马上要问他一些私人问题。他说，告诉我一件你从未告诉过任何人的事。查尔斯说，没有。而在我们深入这场疯狂的会议之前，因为有一个被删减的片段我想读给你们听。
Let's take a break. Yes. And we'll be right back. All right, so we're back. We're in the conference room. Michael is desperately trying to get to know Charles Minor. Charles Minor is having none of it. I know somewhere in an NBC vault, there's got to be tons of extra footage because in
我们先休息一下。好的，我们马上回来。好了，我们回来了。我们在会议室里。迈克尔正拼命想要了解查尔斯·迈纳。查尔斯·迈纳根本不吃那一套。我知道在NBC的某个资料库里，一定有大量的额外花絮，因为在
the script, there were all these bits and you know Steve went off script. So the scene would have started like this. Hi, Charles. Hi, Michael. And then Michael would go, Charles, Charles, Charles, Bobarles, Banana, Fana, Fana, Fafarles. And then he stops and the script says, long beat. And then he goes, Mimo, Mo, Marles, very long beat. And then at the same time, Charles goes Michael and Michael goes Charles.
剧本里，有所有这些小桥段，而且你知道史蒂夫是不按剧本演的。所以这个场景原本是这样开始的。嗨，查尔斯。嗨，迈克尔。然后迈克尔会说，查尔斯，查尔斯，查尔斯，博巴尔斯，香蕉，法娜，法娜，法法尔斯。然后他停下来，剧本上写着，长长的停顿。然后他说，米莫，莫，马尔斯，非常长的停顿。然后与此同时，查尔斯说了迈克尔，迈克尔说了查尔斯。
That's how it would have started. Wow. I'm sad that's not there. Well, instead, Michael asks Charles two questions in a row. What is your wife's name and where did you work before this? And Charles says, Satecoy Steel. And Michael says, oh, what a cool name for your wife. And he's like, no, I worked at Satecoy Steel.
事情就是这样开始的。哇。真遗憾那段没播出来。好吧，相反，迈克尔接连问了查尔斯两个问题。你妻子叫什么名字，你之前在哪里工作？查尔斯说，萨特科伊钢铁公司。迈克尔说，哦，你妻子名字真酷。然后他说，不，我曾在萨特科伊钢铁公司工作。
And the performance by Steve as Michael when he realizes that Charles isn't even a paper man. Yeah. He's like, does David Wallace know this? You don't even come from paper. Yeah. We got a lot of fan mail about the Satecoy Steel. People noticed that we film on Satecoy Street and they wanted to know, is this a real company
史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔在意识到查尔斯甚至不是个卖纸的人时的那种表演。对。他说，大卫·华莱士知道这事吗？你根本不是做纸品出身的。对。我们收到了很多关于萨特科伊钢铁公司的粉丝来信。人们注意到我们在萨特科伊街拍摄，他们想知道，这是一家真正的公司
or just a nod to where we filmed? It is not a real company. It was just named after our street. And I love it. I did too. However, I did find this. When I was looking up Satecoy Steel. What did you find, Mom Detective?
还是只是对我们拍摄地点的致敬？它不是一家真正的公司。它只是以我们这条街的名字命名的。我很喜欢。我也很喜欢。不过，我确实发现了这个。当我在查萨特科伊钢铁公司的时候。你发现了什么，妈咪侦探？
I found out that there is a profile for Charles Minor, Regional Manager of Satecoy Steel on LinkedIn. Oh, great. As well as profiles for all the office characters. There's like a ton of Dwight K. Shrut profiles, but you can find all of us on LinkedIn. I love that. You are very right, Angela, when you say that Michael is very furious to find out that Charles has not worked in paper and he calls David Wallace immediately.
我发现领英上有一个查尔斯·迈纳的个人资料，他是萨特科伊钢铁公司的区域经理。哦，太棒了。还有所有办公室角色的个人资料。有成吨的德怀特·K·施鲁特个人资料，但你能在领英上找到我们所有人。我太喜欢了。安吉拉，你说得非常对，迈克尔发现查尔斯没有从事过纸业工作后非常愤怒，他立刻给大卫·华莱士打了电话。
He does this thing as my dad would say, he went in there wide open. Oh. That was an expression my dad would say, which meant, here comes hell, right? So Michael is in a frenzy now. There was a scene that led up to his phone call to David between him and Dwight and they are pacing and they're speaking in hushed tones. While Michael's dialing, Dwight saying nothing, not even paper plates. Michael's like, nothing.
正如我爸爸所说的那样，他这叫“毫无保留地冲了进去”。哦。那是我爸爸常说的一个词，意思是，麻烦要来了，对吧？所以迈克尔现在陷入了疯狂。在他给大卫打电话之前，他和德怀特之间还有一个场景，他们在踱步，压低声音说话。迈克尔在拨号时，德怀特一言不发，甚至连纸盘子都不提。迈克尔说，什么都没有。
The man is a still worker. He probably has no idea how paper's made. Hello. And then the phone picks up. That's the energy that would have started the scene that was in the script. And Michael cannot get David Wallace on the phone. Dwight says, you cannot give up so easily. All right.
这人是个钢铁工人。他可能根本不知道纸是怎么造出来的。喂。然后电话接通了。这就是剧本里原本用来开启这个场景的能量。而且迈克尔根本无法让大卫·华莱士接电话。德怀特说，你不能这么轻易放弃。好吧。
You've got to charm them. Rain could not get through this scene. It's in the bloopers. We have to hear it. Hey there, gorgeous. How you doing today? I'm good. Thank you.
你得迷倒他们。雷恩根本无法演完这一幕。它在花絮里。我们得听听。嘿，美女。今天过得怎么样？我很好。谢谢。
How's it hanging? All right. Listen, my name. He doesn't even sound like Dwight. That's the other thing that I think. He sounds like rain. He does sound like rain. I think that kind of cracked rain up.
最近怎么样？好吧。听着，我的名字。他听起来根本不像德怀特。这是我觉得的另一件事。他听起来像雷恩。他听起来确实像雷恩。我觉得这把雷恩逗乐了。
David Wallace's assistant was played by Suzanne Watson. I'm not exactly sure how she got the role in this show. She mostly works as a producer, but she is going to appear in three more episodes of The Office in season six, and she would have had a scene in this episode as well when Michael eventually goes to corporate. So she wasn't just cast for her voice. She actually, you know, was going to have this recurring role as David Wallace's assistant. Stephanie.
大卫·华莱士的助理是由苏珊·沃森饰演的。我不太确定她是怎么得到这个角色的。她主要担任制片人，但她接下来还要在第六季的《办公室》中出演另外三集，而且在这集中她本来也有一场戏，也就是迈克尔最终去总公司的时候。所以她不只是因为声音被选中的。她其实，你知道的，将拥有大卫·华莱士助理这个常驻角色。斯蒂芬妮。
Stephanie. Stephanie. Oh, to be Stephanie. Taking Michael's calls. Oh, man. So meanwhile, Jim is working at his desk in his tux, and he keeps looking over his shoulder and Charles is there. Yes.
斯蒂芬妮。斯蒂芬妮。哦，真想成为斯蒂芬妮。接听迈克尔的电话。天哪。所以与此同时，吉姆穿着燕尾服在办公桌前工作，他不停地越过肩膀张望，查尔斯就在那里。对。
Looking at him through the blinds of the conference room. And then it pans to Jim, and Jim, like, shakes off the camera, like, mm-mm-mm. And then it whips over to Dwight, and Dwight is so smug and happy. Well, in the script, Dwight had a talking head here. It got deleted, but you got to hear it. Oh, look at me and my pretty tuxedo. I'm so pretty and carefree, and I don't need glasses. And, oh, what's that?
透过会议室的百叶窗看着他。然后镜头切到吉姆，吉姆对镜头摆了摆手，就像在说“不不不”。接着镜头猛地转向德怀特，德怀特显得无比自鸣得意和开心。好吧，在剧本里，德怀特在这里有一段独白。虽然被删了，但你们得听听。哦，看看我和我漂亮的燕尾服。我是如此美丽和无忧无虑，我不需要眼镜。而且，哦，那是什么？
An objective outside observer doesn't find me amusing? A hysterical. That's pretty great. This is making Dwight's year. Hey, guess what? What? Lunch is here. And it's on me.
一个客观的局外观察者觉得我不好笑？太滑稽了。这真是太棒了。这让德怀特度过了美好的一年。嘿，你猜怎么着？什么？午餐到了。我请客。
Charles got lunch for everybody. People are thrilled. Michael's like, I wish you would have told us sooner. I was going to go to the vending machine and get an egg salad. I'm sorry. Is there egg salad in our vending machines? Gross! What vending machine is this?
查尔斯给大家买午餐了。大家都很兴奋。迈克尔说，我希望你能早点告诉我们。我本来打算去自动售货机买一份蛋黄酱沙拉三明治。不好意思。我们的自动售货机里有蛋黄酱沙拉三明治吗？太恶心了！这是什么自动售货机？
We did not have a refrigerated vending machine. No. Charles, though, is like, you still have that option. There's some serious Charles sass in this scene, and my favorite is this one. I do this for every branch I go to. If you do not like it, then I think there are some bagels left over from this morning. Sass. Yes.
我们没有带冷藏功能的自动售货机。没有。不过查尔斯说，你们仍然有这个选择。这场戏里查尔斯真是傲慢得可以，我最喜欢这句。我去过的每个分公司我都这么做。如果你不喜欢，那我想要是还有今天早上剩下的百吉饼的话，你们可以吃那个。傲慢。是的。
That's major sass. Well, you know, in the conference room, Kelly's going to say to Angela, should I seduce Charles? And Angela goes, no. No one wants to see that. But then she sneaks a smile at Charles. I like this rivalry. Mindy and I had so much fun doing this. We had such a blast.
这是极度的傲慢。好吧，你知道的，在会议室里，凯莉对安吉拉说，我要去勾引查尔斯吗？安吉拉说，不。没人想看那个。但接着她冲查尔斯偷偷笑了一下。我喜欢这种竞争关系。明迪和我演这个可太开心了。我们玩得超嗨。
Michael is trying to call David Wallace again, and then we're going to have the scene that is the tipping point for Michael. It's so cringey. Kevin approaches Michael and says he used the wrong calendar for his spreadsheet. The wrong calendar. From 2008. And he has to redo his spreadsheet. Can he come in over the weekend?
迈克尔正试图再次给大卫·华莱士打电话，然后我们要演的那场戏是迈克尔情绪彻底崩溃的导火索。真是尴尬癌都要犯了。凯文走近迈克尔，说他在电子表格里用错了日历。用错了日历。2008年的。他必须重新做电子表格。他能在周末来加班吗？
That would mean overtime. Michael says, yes, Charles says, no, no, we talked about this. And Michael's like, I'm sorry, this is my branch and I like your initiative, Kevin. And yes. And Charles just shuts him down. He's like, that's not how we're going to do this. And how does Michael respond? Michael starts doing that like six year old thing, that echo thing where you just repeat
那就意味着要算加班费。迈克尔说，可以，查尔斯说，不行，不行，我们讨论过这个。迈克尔说，不好意思，这是我的分公司，我很欣赏你的积极性，凯文。没错。而查尔斯直接压制了他。他说，我们可不这么办事。迈克尔是怎么回应的？迈克尔开始学起六岁小孩的那种把戏，就是那种鹦鹉学舌，别人说什么他就重复
what the other person is saying. Yeah. I know you are. I know you are. And then it's like going on and on and everyone in the bullpen is saying, Michael. Stop it. Please. Pam has a talking head where she says she can tell how upset Michael is by which comedy
别人说的话。对。我知道你是。我知道你是。然后没完没了，大办公室里的每个人都在说，迈克尔。停下。求你了。潘姆有一段独白，她说她能从迈克尔使用的喜剧
routine he uses and how infantile and immature he gets. He has skipped over the Ace Ventura butt routine, which never happens. She knows this is bad. He skipped over Ace Ventura butt routine. That's the talking butt. Yeah, I know the talking butt. I know it. He's going to take all that energy and he's going to say, all right, fine.
套路以及他变得多么幼稚和不成熟，看出他有多沮丧。他跳过了神探阿杰的“屁股说话”梗，这可是从来没有发生过的事。她知道情况不妙。他跳过了神探阿杰的屁股说话梗。就是那个会说话的屁股。对，我知道那个会说话的屁股。我知道。他要带着所有的能量说，好吧，行。
Party planning committee in the conference room. And there was a thing in the script where he was like, you guys just pitch me ideas because maybe planning my party will make me feel better. I remember shooting the scene. We had a hard time getting through it. I bet. I bet. Well, while you guys start pitching party ideas, Charles is going to go over to Phyllis
派对策划委员会去会议室。剧本里原本还有个情节，他说，你们就给我提点建议吧，因为策划我的派对也许会让我感觉好受点。我还记得拍摄这场戏的情景。我们拍得很艰难。我敢说。我敢说。好吧，当你们开始筹划派对点子时，查尔斯走向菲莉丝
and say, you know, what is the PPC? And Phyllis says it's the party planning committee and they spend hours planning parties. And then Phyllis would have had a talking head. And I so wish it had made it in. Are you ready for some Phyllis sass? Here's her talking head. I built that house. I can burn it down.
说，你知道的，PPC是什么？菲莉丝说是派对策划委员会，他们花好几个小时策划派对。然后菲莉丝本来有一段独白。我真希望这段能播出来。你们准备好听菲莉丝的毒舌了吗？这是她的独白。那房子是我盖的。我也能把它烧了。
That was in the script. Oh, Phyllis. I know. I love this side of Phyllis, especially when it's not directed at Angela. Well, in that moment when Charles is talking to Phyllis at 14 minutes, 48 seconds, you get a real good shot of this silver, insulated coffee mug that he's been carrying around all day. Do you know what it said on it?
剧本里确实有这句。哦，菲莉丝。我知道。我喜欢菲莉丝的这一面，尤其是当它不是针对安吉拉的时候。好吧，在14分48秒查尔斯和菲莉丝说话的那个瞬间，你可以非常清晰地看到他一整天都随身带着的那个银色保温咖啡杯。你知道上面写的是什么吗？
What? Satacoist steel. Oh, nice detail. Way to go, Phil Shea, because when Charles enters the conference room, he is holding that Satacoist steel coffee mug I level to Michael Scott. And I don't know, I just felt like it was subliminally pissing Michael off. Just poking the bear. Yeah.
什么？萨特科伊钢铁公司。哦，好细节。干得好，道具师菲尔，因为当查尔斯走进会议室时，他手里拿着那个萨特科伊钢铁公司的咖啡杯，高度正对着迈克尔·斯科特。我不知道，我只是觉得这在潜意识里把迈克尔气坏了。就是在戳熊的痛处。对。
Just rubbing it in his face. Well, Charles wants to know what the heck they're doing in there. He now has been tipped off by Phyllis that this is a big waste of time. And he starts to look over Jim's shoulder and he's like, what is a two-way petting zoo? And Jim is really embarrassed and he says, you pet the animals, they pet you back. We could not get through that. Two-way petting zoo did us in every time.
就是在往他伤口上撒盐。好吧，查尔斯想知道他们在里面到底在搞什么鬼。他现在已经被菲莉丝提醒，这是在浪费大量时间。他开始看着吉姆的肩膀说，什么是双向抚摸动物园？吉姆真的很尴尬，他说，你摸动物，动物也摸你。我们根本拍不下去。双向抚摸动物园每次都把我们整崩溃。
I got a little bit curious. You did not look up two-way petting zoo. I did. Oh no. Is that a burning man? Because I have a friend who was in a petting zoo at Burning Man. What? What is that?
我有点好奇。你该不会去查了什么是双向抚摸动物园吧。我查了。哦，不。那是火人节的活动吗？因为我有个朋友在火人节的动物园里待过。什么？那是什么？
What is that? Okay. This is someone I did improv with. And I'll never forget, you know, she's kind of like a free spirit. And I was at the airport, this is years ago, and I see her running through the airport and it looked like she had like, I don't know, she had like a carry-on, but you could see sort of like a onesie poking out of it. She's running through the airport and I'm like, hi, and she's like, hi.
那是什么？好吧。这是我一起演过即兴喜剧的人。我永远不会忘记，你知道的，她有点像那种崇尚自由灵魂的人。那是好几年前，我在机场，我看到她一路小跑着穿过机场，看起来她带了，我不知道，她带了一个随身行李，但你能看到某种连体衣从里面露出来。她跑过机场，我说，嗨，她说，嗨。
And she's like, so good to see you. And I was like, you too. She's like, where are you going? And I was like, I'm going to see my folks. I said, what about you? And she said, oh, I'm going to Burning Man. I'm in the petting zoo this year. And so I had to say, what, what, what is the petting zoo?
她说，很高兴见到你。我说，我也是。她说，你要去哪儿？我说，我要去看望我的父母。我说，你呢？她说，哦，我要去火人节。我今年在动物园里。所以我不得不问，动物园到底是，是，是什么？
She was like, well, you know, you dress up as animals and let people pet you. Wow. Yeah. Yeah. I mean. That's what I thought of when you said that. I did not know that. I mean, I found out that there's no such thing as a two-way petting zoo where actual animals
她说，哦，你知道的，你打扮成动物，让别人摸你。哇。对。对。我是说。你这么说的时候，我想到的就是这个。我以前真不知道。我是说，我发现根本没有什么双向抚摸动物园，也就是真正的动物去抚摸人类，但我确实不知道火人节上还有这种人类动物园。你以为动物会抚摸人类吗？你知道吗，大姐？我不知道。我承认。我不知道。我不知道谷歌上怎么说，但我确实查到了这个。什么？
pet the humans, but I did not know about this human petting zoo at Burning Man. Did you think animals would pet humans? You know what, lady? I didn't know. I admit. I don't know. I don't know about Google, but I did find this. What?
双向抚摸动物园显然就像是一个委婉的说法，用来形容那种非常激烈热烈的情热交融。就像你会说，哦，昨晚我和我男朋友来了一场真正的双向抚摸动物园。得了吧。谁会这么说话？但你让我想起了六年级健康教育课上的那些闪回，当时我们有个教练教我们六年级的健康教育，他说，有时候会有厚厚的衬垫。有时你会觉得，哦，厚厚的衬垫。
Two-way petting zoo is apparently like a euphemism for describing like a really intense passionate sexual encounter. Like you would be like, oh, me and my boyfriend had a real two-way petting zoo last night. No, come on. Who talks like that? But you are giving me flashbacks of like sixth grade sex ed where like we had a coach teach us sixth grade sex ed, and he was like, sometimes there's heavy padding. Sometimes you're like, oh, heavy padding.
厚厚的衬垫。对。我不知道。好吧，我们不知道吉姆是什么意思，但我们知道他超级尴尬。好吧，查尔斯受够了。他要立刻解散PPC。这就是迈克尔彻底情绪失控的时候。本来还有一个被删减的片段，他在其中为保留PPC进行了辩护。
Heavy padding. Yeah. I don't know. Well, we don't know what Jim meant, but we know he's super embarrassed. Well, Charles has had enough. He wants to dissolve the PPC effective immediately. This is where Michael completely flips out. And there was a deleted scene where he made a defensive argument to keep the PPC.
哦，我们得听听。派对策划委员会是这个机构中的一个机构。这是我在90年代中期成立的一个组织，为了庆祝《红粉联盟》发行激光影碟。它已经成为这里的传统。这是对我们所有人都很重要的事。我们为《红粉联盟》的派对做了什么？做一个属于你自己的披萨派对。
Oh, we need to hear it. The party planning committee is an institution in this institution. It is something that I incorporated in the mid-90s to celebrate the laser disc release of a League of their Own. It has become a tradition here. It is something that is important to all of us. What did we do for League of their Own party? A pizza of your own party.
我那时甚至都没在这儿工作。我只是听过这些故事。好吧，谢谢你，德怀特。那只需要一个人花五天，不对，五分钟的时间。真的吗？五分钟。是的，然后场景就在这里接上了，他直接爆发了，他说，你
Make your own pizza. I didn't even work here then. I just heard the stories. Okay, thank you Dwight. That should take five minutes of one person's day. Really? Five minutes. Yeah, and then that's where the scene picks up and he just goes off and he's like, you
甚至不知道纸是怎么造出来的。它不像钢铁。你不用把它放进熔炉里。然后他开始哭泣。他在离开的时候推倒了一把椅子。这不在剧本里。他大发脾气。啊，我想起来了。
don't even know how paper is made. It's not like steel. You don't put it in a furnace. And he starts like to cry. And he shoves over a chair on his way out. That was not in the script. He has a whole tantrum. Ah, I remember.
迈克尔离开后，吉姆试图和查尔斯重新开始。对。这引发了第二波粉丝来信狂潮，很多人写信来。这是一段引言。我很高兴终于能讨论我在整个系列中最看不惯的事情了。哦，天哪。在16分40秒的时候，吉姆说，他是办公室里很棒的二把手。查尔斯回答说他不知道还有这个职位。
After Michael leaves, Jim is going to attempt to start over with Charles. Yeah. And this created fan mail, fan mail, flurry number two, a lot of people wrote in. This is a quote. I am so excited to finally get to discuss my biggest pet peeve in the whole series. Oh my goodness. What at 16 minutes, 40 seconds, Jim says, he's a great number two for the office. And Charles responds by saying he didn't know that position existed.
然后吉姆有点像在跳踢踏舞，他说，嗯，一开始这是为德怀特虚设的，但后来，你知道的，迈克尔把它给了我，然后这一切以查尔斯说了一句“这个虚构的职位对你很重要吗”而告终。好吧，大家都很生气。生谁的气？是这样的。我是说，人们发来了大量证据来证明吉姆
And then Jim kind of like tap dances and he's like, well, at first it was made up for Dwight, but then, you know, Michael gave it to me and kind of all ends with Charles being like, is this made up position important to you? Yeah. Well, people are pee-o'd. At who? Here's the thing. I mean, people sent in lists of evidence to say that this number two position that Jim
担任的这个二把手职位是真实存在的。这不是一个虚构的职位，查尔斯应该知道这一点。以下是证据。在分公司倒闭那集里，简对吉姆谈到回斯克兰顿的事，她说，引述一下，“我们想邀请你担任该分公司的二把手。”在公司合并时，迈克尔在开除托尼后给简打电话。他试图把责任推给德怀特，说“来自我二把手的糟糕建议”，简说，“吉姆就是你的二把手。
holds is real. It is not a made up position and that Charles should know that. Here's the evidence. In branch closing, Jan is talking to Jim about going back to Scranton and she says, quote, we'd like to offer you the number two position at that branch. In the merger, Michael is on the phone with Jan after firing Tony. He tries to blame Dwight by saying bad advice from my number two and Jan says, Jim is your number two.
我给你发过关于这事的备忘录。”在公司合并时，吉姆向德怀特证实这份工作伴随着加薪。哦，是的。在班尼哈纳圣诞节那集里，当潘姆把圣诞礼物送给吉姆时，吉姆引用他的晋升为由拒绝了。同样是在班尼哈纳圣诞节，德怀特称自己为排名第三，他最终承认了吉姆作为排名第二的权威。这是他们试图让策划派对的委员会合法化的时候。
I sent you a memo about this. In the merger, Jim confirms to Dwight that the job comes with a pay raise. Oh, yeah. In Benihana Christmas, when Pam gives her Christmas gift to Jim, he turns it down using quote his promotion as an excuse. Also in a Benihana Christmas, Dwight refers to himself as the ranking number three and he finally concedes to Jim's authority as ranking number two. This is when they're trying to validate the committee to plan parties.
他们陷入了这场争论。在《回归》一集中，安迪对吉姆说，我很高兴能在你手下直接工作。在《女性赞赏日》中，德怀特对吉姆说，你可能是第二负责人，但这并不意味着你凌驾于法律之上。这是一个真实的职位。我同意大家的看法，是的。我觉得吉姆没有表达好，然后他自己慌了神。我也这么觉得。
They get in this whole argument. In the return, Andy tells Jim, I'm thrilled to be working directly beneath you. In women's appreciation, Dwight tells Jim, you may be second command, but that does not put you above the law. This is a real position. I agree with everybody that yes. I think Jim doesn't present it well and then he gets flustered. I think so too.
顺便说一句，大家做得很棒，考证得很详细。是的。我印象深刻。我要向劳拉·K、亚历山大·K、赛·L、丹·C、艾米丽·M以及其他人表示感谢。干得漂亮。我喜欢。大家都很激动。我喜欢。
By the way, great research, everyone. Yeah. I'm very impressed. Let me give a shout out to Laura K., Alexandra K., Cy L., Dan C., Emily M., and others. Well done. I like it. People were fired up. I like it.
简直是粉丝来信的暴风雪。是的。吉姆在查尔斯面前就是讨不到好。还有更多的场景显示他在一整天里不断吃瘪。其中一个发生在公司前台。哦，我记得拍这个。我们能听听吗？他真的很不喜欢我。
It was a fan mail blizzard. Yeah. Jim just can't win with Charles. There were more scenes where he just got busted throughout the day. One of them happened at front reception. Oh, I remember shooting this. Can we hear that? He really doesn't like me.
但你看起来真精神。谢谢。我工作真的很努力。我一直在打电话。我完成了一笔销售。我更新了通讯录。这就是你的一天，吉姆？什么？
But you look so dapper. Thank you. I'm working so hard. I was hitting the phones. I closed the sale. I updated my contact list. Is this your day, Jim? What?
我……嘿，去告诉他你更新了通讯录。我要是告诉他……你在嘲笑我？真的吗？今天？好像我手头的事还不够多似的。对不起。
I... Hey, go tell him you updated your contact list. I would tell him if it... You're mocking me? Really? Today? Like, I don't have enough going on. I'm sorry.
吃块糖吧。谢谢。亲爱的，你介意在你的办公桌上吃那个吗？我不想让他一直看到我们在一起。好吧，当我不得不说那句台词“你能在办公桌上吃那个吗”的时候，我们根本拍不下去。这把我和约翰笑得太惨了，以至于潘姆说，你们能不能去别的地方演？
Have a candy. Thank you. Sweetie, do you mind eating that at your desk? I don't want him to keep seeing us together. Okay, when I had to say that line, could you eat that at your desk? We could not get through that. That made John and I laugh so hard that Pam was like, could you just do that somewhere else?
他还会，你们可能看不到，对吧？如果你有DVD的话，它在被删减的片段里。当潘姆那样说的时候，约翰饰演的吉姆面无表情地看着镜头，就像在说，你在开玩笑吧？我都记得。我记得太清楚了。好吧，迈克尔要开车去总公司。他要在男厕所门口堵住大卫·华莱士。
He also, which you guys can't see it, right? It's in the deleted scenes if you have the DVDs. When Pam says that, John, as Jim, looks at the camera, like super deadpan, like, are you kidding me? I remember all of that. I remember it so clearly. Well, Michael's going to drive to corporate. He's going to confront David Wallace as he's leaving the men's room.
这是迈克尔的经典动作。对不起，伙计们，安吉拉今天对我也这么干了。我确实干了。我在我们休息的时候去了洗手间。好吧，这里只有……首先，这里只有一个洗手间。还有一个走廊。对。
This is a classic Michael move. I'm sorry, you guys, but Angela did that to me today. I did. I went to the restroom during our break. Well, there's only... Okay, first of all, there's only one bathroom here. And one hallway. Yeah.
就在那儿。你有个邮件想给我看，所以她刚从洗手间出来，我就说，你看这个。然后我说，你刚刚对我用了迈克尔·斯科特式的套路。对。不管怎样，大卫·华莱士，把迈克尔叫了进去。他说，你知道吗？听着，你可以办你的十五周年派对。
It's right there. And you had this email you wanted to show me, so as soon as she came out of the bathroom, I was like, look at this. And I said, you just Michael scotted me. Yeah. Anyway, David Wallace, here's Michael out. And he's like, you know what? Look, you can have your 15th anniversary party.
你可以有无花果。迈克尔一直在唠叨这些无花果。我知道。这里有一个完整的无花果梗。什么？是的，在剧本里。我以为这只是个随兴的梗，我当时觉得太逗了，我就想，这是什么？
You can have the figs. Michael keeps talking about these figs. I know. There was a whole fig runner. What? Yes, in the script. I thought this was just like a random thing and I was so tickled by it, I was like, what is this?
对。对无花果的执念。是的。所以这本该是对前面派对策划场景的一个呼应。迈克尔想要的其中一样东西就是培根卷无花果，对吧？然后还记得当他在取消派对这件事上对查尔斯·迈纳情绪失控的时候吗？他有一整段演讲，他说，会有马车，会有意式烟肉卷无花果，会有霹雳舞者。
Yes. Commitment to having figs. Yeah. So this would have been a callback to an earlier scene when they're doing all the party planning. One of the things Michael wanted was like bacon-wrapped figs, okay? And then remember when he started to spiral out to Charles Minor about canceling the party? He had this whole speech where he was like, there will be horse-drawn carriages, there will be panchetta-wrapped figs, there will be breakdancers.
哇。对。就是那些无花果。无花果。它们已经到了。已经到了。他打算拿它们怎么办？完全正确。
Wow. Yeah. Those are the figs. The figs. They've already arrived. They're arrived. What's he going to do with them? Exactly.
所以大卫·华莱士说，我会去你的派对。你可以吃你的无花果。我会腾出一些资金来促成这事。但迈克尔却说，他笑了笑，你以为他很高兴。然后他说，我不干了。他辞职了。我太惊讶了。太惊人了。
So David Wallace says, I will come to your party. You can have your figs. I will move some money around and make it happen. But Michael says, he smiles and you think he's happy. And then he says, I quit. He quits. I was so surprised. It's amazing.
对。我这里有个真正的题外话要插播。好的。我不知道你们有没有注意到，在这个场景的开始，大卫·华莱士正在从一个斐济水瓶里喝水。我觉得这很随性，因为他把瓶子转了个方向，让你看不到正面的名字，但这显然是斐济水。我当时很困惑，因为我以为他们从不允许我们这么做。
Yeah. I have a real tangent to throw in here. Okay. I don't know if you noticed, but at the very beginning of the scene, David Wallace is drinking water out of a Fiji water bottle. It was really random to me because he's turned the bottle in such a way that you can't see the name facing you, but it's clearly Fiji water. And I was so confused because I thought they never let us do that.
没有。我只是在想，那是他之前一直在喝斐济水，然后它出现在了场景里，他转了过去，因为，你知道的，他是……我不知道，这吸引了我的注意。但这也吸引了我的注意，因为一周前巧合的是，我的家人开始对瓶装水的起源着迷。所以我们现在正处于这样一个阶段，我们的10岁孩子，如果我们吃饭时聊天谈到什么，他就会想去查阅并找出关于它的一切。我想知道他是从哪学来的这招。
No. I just wondered, was that he had been drinking some Fiji water and it ended up in the scene and he turned because, you know, was he, I don't know, I just, it stood out to me. But it also stood out to me because earlier in the week by coincidence, my family became fascinated with the origins of bottled water. So we're in this phase right now where our 10 year old, if we're talking at dinner and we bring up something, he wants to look it up and find out everything about it. I wonder where he gets that.
好吧，我们当时在讨论为学校买新的水瓶，你知道的，那种可重复使用的。这让我们聊到了瓶装水，我儿子最后为我们全家深入研究了一番瓶装水的起源。我想我应该分享一点，既然大卫·华莱士拿着水瓶这事这么巧。好的，这是我儿子的深入研究，我觉得很着迷。
Well, we were discussing getting new water bottles for school, you know, the reusable ones. And this got us on bottled water and my son ended up doing a whole deep dive for our family on the origins of bottled water. And I thought I would share a little bit about it since what the coincidence that David Wallace is holding a water bottle. Okay. This is my son's deep dive and I find it fascinating.
我想你也会觉得，尽管你不是他的妈妈。美国第一家商业分销的瓶装水公司叫做杰克逊温泉，它于1767年在波士顿成立。这就是引发一切的问题：谁制造了第一瓶水？是杰克逊温泉，喝这种水的人认为它具有治疗特性，因为它来自那些矿泉之一，一个天然泉水。其中一个巨头，箭头泉，成立于1917年。这也太早了吧。
And I think you will too, even though you're not his mother. The first commercially distributed bottled water company in America was called Jackson Spa and it was founded in 1767 in Boston. This was the question that launched everything was who made the first bottle of water. It was Jackson Spa and the people who drank the water thought that it held therapeutic properties because it came from like one of those mineral springs, a natural spring. One of the biggies, Arrowhead, was established in 1917. That's so early.
我知道。箭头泉的水取自加利福尼亚州、科罗拉多州和加拿大的山泉。直到今天，它仍然是在加利福尼亚装瓶的。然后我们到了依云。那是直到1978年才建立的，比箭头泉晚了将近70年。他们的水来自法国阿尔卑斯山的一个泉水。大卫·华莱士拿的斐济水来自斐济，但瓶装水的重大转折发生在百事可乐和可口可乐通过销售纯净水进入这个行业的时候。
I know. Arrowhead water is sourced from the mountain springs in California, Colorado and Canada. It's bottled in California even today. Then we get up to Evion. That was not established until 1978, almost 70 years after Arrowhead. Their water comes from a spring in the French Alps. Fiji water, as held by David Wallace, comes from Fiji, but the big shift in bottled water came when Pepsi and Coca-Cola got into the game by selling purified water.
纯净水基本上就是市政自来水，然后通过一种叫做反渗透的过程进行过滤。泉水也是过滤过的，但反渗透才是净化的部分，我猜。这就是纯净的部分。然后我们全家人都在想，什么水最好，纯净水、泉水还是自来水？你知道是什么吗？你猜。自来水。
Purified water is basically municipal tap water, which is then filtered using a process called reverse osmosis. Spring water is also filtered, but the reverse osmosis is what purifies it, I guess. That's the purified part. Then we all wondered as a family, what's the best water, purified, spring, tap? You know what it is? Guess. Tap.
不对。泉水。不对。纯净水。是的。纯净水。反渗透使它比过滤泉水或自来水更纯净。怎么样？
Nope. Spring. Nope. Purified. Yes. Purified water. The reverse osmosis makes it the most pure above filtered spring or tap. How about that?
百事可乐和可口可乐已经在使用纯净水作为他们苏打水的基础了。他们获取水，将其净化，然后加入所有的气泡，然后加入你放进苏打水里的所有其他东西。对他们来说，在把水变成苏打水之前，直接开始把水装瓶真的很简单。好吧，我认为这是一次迷人的深入研究。干得好。我们全家正试图减少塑料的使用。
Pepsi and Coke were already using purified water as the basis of their sodas. They would get water, they would purify it, and then they would add all the bubbles, and then they would add all the other stuff that you put in a soda. It was really easy for them to just start bottling it before they did all the rest of it to make it a soda. Well I think that's a fascinating deep dive. Well done. We are trying as a family to cut down on plastic.
超级难。有太多了。太多一次性塑料了。没错。这正是我们试图避免的。没错。我丈夫刚刚和一家我非常欣赏的公司合作，叫利乐包。哦，天哪。
Super hard. There's so much. So much single-use plastic. That's right. And that's what we're trying to avoid. Exactly. And my husband just worked with this company that I find fascinating called Tetrapack. Oh my gosh.
我看了他为他们制作的视频，太棒了。太惊人了。他们把水装在你能想象到的每一种容器里，汤也是，只要你开始注意利乐包长什么样，它就像纸包装。是的。唯一是塑料而且是回收塑料的部分就是盖子。对。就是高汤装的那种容器。
I watched his video that he made for them, and it was great. It was amazing. They're putting water in everything you can imagine, soup, and it just, if you start to notice what Tetrapack looks like, it's like paper packaging. Yes. And the only thing that's plastic and it's like recycled plastic is the lid. Yeah. It's the thing that like broth comes in.
是的。椰子水，我看到了。盒装牛奶。是的。又一个我想去的工厂。哦，让我们去那个工厂吧。我知道。
Yes. Coconut waters, I see. Box milk. Yep. Fascinating. Another factory that I want to go to. Oh, let's go to the factory. I know.
好吧，回到我们的剧集中，查尔斯要下班离开了。他道了别。安吉拉跑过去说再见，我超级喜欢凯莉和菲莉丝在厨房里的那场戏。凯莉在涂口红。她说，我今晚要让他们给我买牛排，而菲莉丝却说，首先，这里只有我一个人。
Okay. Well, back in our episode, Charles is going to leave for the day. He says goodbye. Angela runs over to say goodbye, and I loved the scene between Kelly and Phyllis in the kitchen. Kelly's putting on lipstick. She's like, I'm going to make them buy me a steak tonight, and Phyllis is like, first of all, I'm the only person here.
因为她一开口就是你们。我知道。我知道。然后她说，我想他已经走了。明迪饰演的凯莉冲出来时，差点撞到镜头，你看到她开始笑场了吗？看到了。我记下了。
Because she starts with you guys. I know. I know. And then she's like, I think he already left. And Mindy, as Kelly goes barreling out, kind of knocks into camera, do you see her start to break? Yes. I wrote it down.
她推门冲出去的时候笑出了声。我还想说，菲莉丝在一天快结束时在喝咖啡。需要提神。这只是个值得注意的小细节。下午提神。凯莉冲向停车场，安吉拉则在外面拿着查尔斯的围巾。在雨中。她顺手牵羊了。
She started to laugh as she pushed through the door. I also want to say Phyllis is drinking coffee at the very end of the day. Needs to pick me up. It's just a little thing to note. Afternoon pick me up. Kelly bolts out to the parking lot, and Angela is out there holding Charles' scarf. In the rain. She swiped it.
哦，是的。百分之百。她顺走了那条围巾。她悄悄地密谋，对吧？凯莉对自己的计划毫不掩饰，但安吉拉却在暗中策划。拍摄这场戏太好玩了。当时真的在下雨。我们必须算准时间，让明迪跑出来，然后我从
Oh yeah. 100%. She swiped that scarf. She quietly plots, OK? Kelly is very out there with what her plans are, but Angela was secretly plotting. Shooting the scene was so much fun. It was actually raining. We had to time it out so that Mindy would come running out, and I would come around the
拐角处走出来，我们看到彼此，然后开始大声向对方怒吼。然后他们说，我们想让你追着她跑。你快跑。于是我们冲了出去。我喜欢和明迪一起演这些戏的每一秒钟。你们得穿着高跟鞋跑。穿着高跟鞋。在湿漉漉的路面上。
corner, and we would see each other, and then start yelling our scene at each other. And then they were like, we want you to chase after her. And you run. So we took off. I loved every second of doing these scenes with Mindy. You guys had to run in your heels. In our heels. On the wet pavement.
我还记得和保罗·费格谈过，等等，安吉拉·马丁在这种情况下会怎么跑？你知道吗？哦，你的角色是怎么跑步的？对，我拍过趣味长跑，但她那时是在为小不点生气而跑步。但这就像，我穿着高跟鞋，安吉拉·马丁会怎么跑？这些都是微小的细节，但弄清楚这些真的很有趣。但这正是你作为演员要做的事。
I also remember talking to Paul Feig about, wait, how would Angela Martin run in this moment? You know? Oh, how does your character run? Yeah, and I had done fun run, but she was angry running about sprinkles. But this was like, I had heels, and how would Angela Martin run? And these are small details, but they're so fun to like figure out. But this is what you do as an actor.
你要为你的角色做出这样的选择：她做某事的方式与你自己的方式不同。对。然后在这之后，我有一段独白。然后我有一段独白，但我们那天并没有拍我的独白。所以他们不得不努力匹配我的头发被打湿后的样子。他们在我的头发上喷了水，在我的脸上洒了水，让睫毛膏顺着脸颊流下来，然后我必须像刚刚从凯莉那里逃跑一样发表
You make these choices for how your character would do something that's different from how you would do it. Yeah. And then after this, I have this talking head. And then I have a talking head, but we did not film my talking head that day. So they had to try to match how wet my hair would have looked. They spritzed my hair with water. They put water on my face, let my mascara run down my cheeks, and then I had to deliver
这段独白。所以我当时就说，什么时候？现在，我问你，在你开始拍摄之前，你会站起来假装跑一下吗？因为我以前做过。当我需要气喘吁吁地登场时，我会原地小跑一下。我没有。哦，那都是，那都是假的。你不需要。
this monologue as if I had just run away from Kelly. So I was like, when did? Now, let me ask you, before you started shooting, did you stand up and like do like a fake run? Because I've done that before. When I have to enter out of breath, I'll do like a little jog in place. I did not. Oh, that's all, that's all fake. You didn't need it.
我不需要。我只是做了这个。凯莉和查尔斯，绝对不可能。他是一个成熟老练的男人。他不需要去翻垃圾桶来寻找伴侣。好的。哇。哇。
I didn't need it. I just did this. Kelly and Charles, absolutely not. He is a sophisticated man. He doesn't need to go dumpster diving for companionship. Okay. Wow. Wow.
演得太好了。谢谢。演得太好了。好吧，听着，那是新老板，不过安吉拉，这其中本来还有些情节的。那些开车的戏。是的。迈克尔开车离开与大卫·华莱士的会面。太搞笑了。
That's really good. Thank you. That's really good. Well, listen, that is new boss, but Angela, there would have been something here. Those driving scenes. Yes. Michael driving away from his meeting with David Wallace. They're so funny.
我在拍摄剧本里读到过，有那么多。他们只是让迈克尔没完没了地说下去。好吧，这里有几个我想让你们听听的被删减片段。哇。哦，天哪。就像末路狂花开车冲下悬崖一样。我真的甚至不确定刚刚发生了什么。我进去了，那是真的，对吧？
I read in the shooting draft, there were so many. They just let Michael go on and on and on. Well, here's a few I want you to hear that made deleted scenes. Wow. Oh boy. Like Thelma and Louise driving off the cliff. I'm really not even sure what just happened. I went inside and that was real, right?
不，妈妈。我不知道我做得对不对。这只是，这只是我所做的。好吧。别让杰夫接电话。我不要，求你了。我不想。你好，先生。
No, mom. I don't know if I did the right thing. It's just, it's just what I did. Okay. Don't put Jeff on the phone. I don't, please. I don't want to. Hello, sir.
你好吗？火车。那是什么？我知道。有一系列的场景，他开始自言自语，比如，我不敢相信发生了这种事。然后他打电话，对吧？然后他歇斯底里地大笑。
How are you? Trains. What is that? I know. There were a series like where he started talking to himself like, I can't believe this happened. Then he calls, right? Then he's laughing hysterically.
然后他在吃披萨。然后他在哭。他们就这么没完没了地演下去。但我很喜欢他妈妈让杰夫接电话。杰夫和火车是怎么回事？有没有哪个早期剧集中，他谈到过杰夫收集火车的情节？我觉得可能吧。
Then he's eating pizza. Then he's crying. They just went on and on. But I loved that his mom put Jeff on the phone. What's up with Jeff and trains? Is there something where he talks about Jeff collecting trains at some point in an earlier episode? I feel like maybe.
也许吧。如果那是片尾彩蛋，那就是迈克尔在车里，离开纽约，他在车里经历了一系列的情绪和碎碎念。好吧，这一切都将引出整个系列中我个人最喜欢的角色剧情之一，也就是针对我的角色潘姆。那就是当迈克尔创办自己的纸业公司时，潘姆跟着他一起去了。我已经迫不及待想看这些剧集了。我等不及了。
Maybe. If it had been the tag, it would have been Michael in the car, leaving New York, and all these series of emotions and little snippets in his car. Well, this whole thing is going to lead to one of my personal favorite storylines of the entire series for my character, Pam. And that is when Michael starts his own paper company and Pam goes with him. I can't wait to watch these episodes. I can't wait.
好了，伙计们，这就是新老板。我们希望你们度过愉快的一周，我们下周见。回头见。再见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理
All right, you guys, that was new boss. We hope you're having a great week and we'll be here next week. See you then. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate
制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科伊。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的“办公室女士”，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium上免费试用一个月，使用代码：OFFICE。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
制片人是艾ins利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡皮树》。要收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。在 Stitcher Premium 注册即可免费试用一个月，优惠码为 OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。